el rugir de las brasas y un cielo
naranja lleno de humo incendios
forestales como este al sur de burdeos
están causando estragos en todo el oeste
y el sur de Europa en el suroeste de
Francia el llorón más de mil hectáreas
de bosques se han convertido en cenizas
en menos de 24 horas unas 6000 personas
han sido evacuadas los bomberos de todo
el país han acudido a intentar Apagar
las llamas
es un incendio que no está controlado la
situación no es buena el fuego se ha
propagado rápidamente debido a la sequía
había viento esta tarde y con esta ola
de calor Eso hace que las condiciones
sean difíciles
en Portugal los recientes incendios
forestales han revivido la situación de
2017 cuando más de 100 personas murieron
en los incendios forestales luchando con
temperaturas abrazadoras y fuertes
vientos más de mil bomberos han estado
trabajando sin descanso para evitar que
las llamas tomen ciudades y pueblos
no recuerdo relacionada como lo que está
sucediendo hoy llevo aquí 50 años y
nunca he visto nada parecido porque está
en todas partes está aquí está allí
y Portugal con temperaturas de más de 40
grados Celsius está la aleta máxima la
vecina España también lucha contra las
llamas unos 300 bomberos combaten un
incendio forestal con la ayuda de 17
aviones y helicópteros el gobierno
afirma que se han quemado unas 70.000
hectáreas desde enero lo que representa
casi el doble de la media de los últimos
10 años